movie number one is called the black
hole in the opening scene of the first
movie we are introduced to a guy named
Charlie who is working alone at his
office during the night shift his facial
expression clearly reflects his
discontent with the mundane nature of
his job in one instance Charlie has seen
photocopying some of the office
documents but the photocopy machine does
not appear to be functioning well as a
result of this he presses the button
repeatedly and even resorts to kicking
the machine a short while later a sheet
of A4 sized paper comes out of the
machine with just a large black circle
drawn on it this only intensifies his
frustration as he believes that
something is wrong with the machine he
puts the A4 sized paper aside and tries
checking for any flaws in the machine
but finds none feeling tired Charlie
takes a sip of his coffee and places the
cup on top of the paper in an unexpected
turn of events the cup falls through the
black hole on the paper leaving him in
utter shock he then slowly puts his hand
into the circle which actually looks
like a hole and retrieves his coffee cup
at this point Charlie realizes that this
black hole acts like a portal enabling
one to reach inaccessible objects Beyond
any kind of barrier excited by this
Revelation he decides to conduct several
experiments with it at first he places
the paper on the vending machine and
puts his hand inside stealing his
favorite chocolates realizing that he
can go much further than that he quickly
goes to the lock locker room and places
the A4 paper on one of the lockers he
then reaches his hand inside and starts
to steal the stacks of money from there
as his greed intensifies he tries to
delve deeper into the portal for more
money eventually he crawls entirely
inside after which the paper slips and
falls off the locker thus trapping his
greedy little raccoon ass within second
movie exit strategy at the start of the
second film a fireman Matt goes to meet
with his younger brother Shane at a
restaurant as Matt strikes a
conversation Shane surprisingly
completes each of his sentences before
he does moreover he instructs him to go
to ESPN live stream and watch a football
match between Liverpool and Manchester
United Shane then predicts the exact
time when a player Roberto firmino will
score the first goal when the event
transpires Matt is left bewildered in
the midst of their conversation Shane's
watch alarm rings and he emphasizes that
they have to leave right now as they
drive away Shane explains that a fire
will break out in the forest of Pines
Road this afternoon so they must get
there and stop it before it happens
perplexed Matt questions how he knows
about all of these future events to
which Shane reveals that he has been
trapped in a Time Loop and has been
living the same day for a long time now
he then predicts that the car's Tire
will blow in a few seconds and it's soon
does as a result they pull over on the
side of the road and start replacing the
tire Matt is still confused as he is not
able to comprehend the ongoing situation
but he trusts his brother despite
meeting him after 4 years after a while
of driving the two arrive at the forest
path but their way is blocked by a
barricade and a guard Matt suggests
breaking through it but Shane replies
that they have tried that before which
resulted in a fatal crash in a bed to
try something new Shane approaches the
guard and informs him that he has found
his missing dog he also provides him
with an address making the dog owner
happy the guard then leaves to retrieve
his pet while the two brothers make
their way into the forest on foot Matt
wonders if it was hard for him to find
that missing dog to which Shane responds
that he was the one who abducted it
after some time the duo comes across a
group of little girls playing with fire
Matt quickly blows out the flame and
instructs the children to go back home
he is glad that the potential forest
fire has now been averted however his
assumption proves to be wrong when he
receives an emergency message on his
pager alerting him to a fire in the city
upon hearing this news Matt realizes
that his brother deliberately brought
him here to distract him from the actual
fire incident upon demanding an
explanation Shane finally admits that he
has been reliving this Loop in an
attempt to save Matt from the city fire
he claims that they tried to stop it
hundreds of times but in each instance
Matt ended up dead even when he managed
to rescue a few people he would never
make it out alive as a result of this
Shane started looking for another exit
to the maze away from the fire goes on
to say that he spent several days
searching for locations calibrating the
shortest safe distance away and found
this one this Revelation infuriates Matt
and he shouts that he does not have to
save him because it is his
responsibility as a firefighter to save
people he also asserts that he does not
care about the time Loop and that the
only reason he accompanied him is
because he wanted to spend time with his
brother after this heated argument Matt
asks for the car keys to drive back to
save people's lives but Shane throws
them away he then tries to stop his
brother but accidentally pushes him this
causes Matt to hit his head on a pointed
piece of wood and die on the spot Shane
is devastated that his brother again met
with the same fate despite his foolproof
plan ultimately making him realize that
he can't escape this maze the scene then
cuts to another timeline and we see the
two brothers meet in the same restaurant
as before this time Shane does not act
smart and just listens to his brother
without any interference shortly after
his watch alarm rings but he dismisses
it choosing to spend quality time with
his brother without the burden of the
time Loop movie three laboratory
condition the third movie opens with a
physician Emma Holloway who discovers
that one of her patients has gone
missing from the hospital Ward puzzled
she inquires about it to the front desk
but doesn't find any clues shortly after
one of the staff members tells her that
the patient has passed away leaving her
bewildered tension heightens when
another staff member reveals that the
morg hasn't received the body yet Emma
then orders the staff to search the
entire Hospital while she walks outside
to light up a cigarette during this
moment she notices an ambulance driving
away making her suspicious as a result
she Tails it in her car leading her to a
secret lab facility she cautiously makes
her way inside where she witnesses her
patient being escorted into a room Emma
then confronts one of the workers Robins
demanding her patient back as they get
into an argument the head of the
laborator story margorie Cain intervenes
she introduces herself as the chair of
The Graduate School of Neuroscience and
also explains that they are carrying out
an experiment to prove the existence of
the Soul she believes that the soul is a
physical entity that can be extracted
from the human body what an idiot Robins
further guides Emma through the chamber
explaining its intricate details he
highlights their capability to detect
and measure any Force entering or
exiting the chamber turns out that the
chamber functions almost almost like an
atomic net preventing even microscopic
entities like light and air from passing
through margerie then requests Emma to
support them in their experiment and
help prove their hypothesis despite her
initial hesitation Emma eventually
agrees shortly after a young lab worker
Alice shows up at the scene with Emma's
patient who appears to be in critical
condition seeing this Emma insists on
transferring the elderly patient to the
ICU but margerie shows her his medical
report pointing out that he won't
survive much longer as a result she asks
for Emma's permission to conduct the
experiment on the old man and study his
dying process in order to convince her
Marjorie asserts that her patient's
death can hold great significance in
their laboratory rather than in the
hospital with the final consent of Emma
the patient is sent to a highly secured
testing chamber as the experiment
commences the team observes it through a
large glass window outside not long
after the patient's Health begins to Det
deteriorate causing their systems and
sensors to start beeping following this
the laboratory Personnel rushed to their
desks to closely analyze the dying
process Emma appears to be concerned for
her patient but she can only watch
helplessly the old man then struggles
for some time before ultimately passing
away a short while later Emma
experiences a vision of the patient Soul
wandering within the secure chamber she
tries to alert everyone about it but
nobody else can see it just then Dan
another worker in the lab notices some
kind of force attempting to enter the
chamber and promptly shares the readings
with the team while the crew are behind
the monitor Emma walks closer to the
glass chamber and Witnesses the
frightened Soul desperately attempting
to make its way out the soul even pleads
with Emma for help which makes her feel
very bad unable to continue the
experiment any longer she quickly turns
off the power supply of the entire lab
and unlocks the chamber door finally
releasing the old man's Soul the other
staff members rush to stop her but they
are already too late as soon as they
restore the electricity robins and Dan
feel a strange sensation within their
bodies Robins describes it as malevolent
while Dan labels it as evil curious
margorie wants to feel the same so she
instructs Robins to open the chambers's
door she has decided to enter the place
herself before doing so Robins asks Emma
if she sees anything inside when the
ladder takes a look she notices several
horrifying soul walls including those of
animals and a young girl with a child
the girl signals Emma to keep quiet and
not reveal their presence heeding her
request Emma denies seeing anyone inside
and gives him the green light to open
the door eager to witness what unfolds
next movie four other side of the box at
the beginning of the fourth movie we see
a couple Ben and Rachel who are cooking
dinner together and flirting
simultaneously their romantic moment is
abruptly interrup rupted by a ring at
the door as Ben peeps through the window
he notices that it is their old friend
Shawn Rachel does not want to see him
revealing that they share a bad history
as a result she walks inside the bedroom
while Ben invites him in we see that
Shawn is holding a gift box which he
hands to Ben believing that he is doing
this to apologize for what happened in
the past Ben accepts it after a while of
awkward conversation Shawn asks him if
Rachel is at home however Ben does not
want him to meet her so he lies saying
that she went to her parents house
following this Shawn insists Ben open
the box right away the ladder agrees and
opens it to find nothing but absolute
Dark Void before Ben can ask about the
details Shawn hurly leaves the place
apologizing to him repeatedly left in a
confused State Ben grabs a flashlight
and uses it to look into the void but
its light also fails to penetrate the
darkness he then takes a pencil and
drops it inside the box but there is no
sound of the pencil hitting the bottom
curious Ben tries to put his hand inside
but is stopped by his girlfriend just
then Ben recalls a letter that was
attached to the present box in it Shawn
has warned him not to divert his gaze
from the box he also apologizes for
giving it to him citing his lack of
choice while trying to comprehend the
meaning of the letter the pencil that he
had dropped rolls towards his feet Ben
picks it up and then as he turns his
gaze back to the box he is startled by
the sight of a creepy half head coming
out from the box they try talking to the
mysterious man but the guy doesn't speak
a word Ben slowly moves to reach his
phone but the man keeps his Gaze fixated
on him he then dials Sha's number but
the latter does not pick up the call
after numerous failed attempts Ben
suggests that they run away from the
house but Rachel reminds him that they
aren't supposed to avert their eyes from
the unsettling man shortly after she
comes up with an idea and the pair
decide to look away for 3 seconds to
check its consequence quences when they
turn their sight back they see the man's
two hands clutching onto the Box's Edge
appearing as if he is attempting to
climb out sensing the imminent danger
Ben asks his girlfriend to keep watch
over the Box while he decides to go out
in search of Shawn Rachel is clearly
terrified since she doesn't want to be
left alone with this Eerie figure
however Ben somehow manages to convince
her and handser a kitchen knife before
leaving on the way he calls his friend
again and finally receives an answer
this time Shawn freaks out upon learning
that he has left the box at home with
Rachel he states that he had given the
box to Ben and that he was the one who
had to keep an eye on it not Rachel
hearing this Ben is concerned about his
girlfriend's safety so he rushes back
home disregarding Sean's warning upon
arrival he finds the house shrouded in
darkness and disarray with no sign of
his girlfriend just then he hears some
sound emanating from the basement
prompting him to head down there with a
flashlight he cautiously descends the
stairs and notices the creepy man taking
a shower there in a blink of an eye the
man vanishes which scares Ben's heart
out he proceeds to escape upstairs only
to discover that the basement door is
blocked by some shadowy figures these
figures also follow the same pattern of
the creepy man and move when they are
not being looked at the situation
further intensifies when Ben sees the
creepy man on the other side now Ben is
trapped as turning towards one side
attracts the mysterious entity from the
other side unable to keep his eyes on
both sides simultaneously these Eerie
figures get closer turn by turn by turn
and the lights abruptly go out subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching